tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su etv
non credo di averla mai detta in vita
mia sta frase proprio credo e poi non ne
sono sicuro sito ragazzi ci stiamo
avvicinando a natale stavolta voglio
provare a fare i livelli solo di natale
se riesco suv test track fatto di
provare a vedere che cos'è presse space
to drive break cos'è quella roba dietro
premi a bra bravo zio va il retro ma il
retro
fatemi vedere la partita partenza epica
tipo così perfetto da michael avanti olè
olè allora mi chiama benissimo sta
macchina c'era chi è che la facciamo
il sospettato un braccio ho fatto è che
non ho la patente ragazzi sono non
sarebbe successo meno male che l'hanno
progettata per the cappottarsi se non
era un problema comunque ragazzi a parte
questo quali senso se volete nei
prossimi episodi una scampagnata da
qualche parte dove guida non sa che
dietro ci stà luke dovrebbero metterlo
come personaggio disponibile non c'è
anche con la macchina bellissimo che in
user bayern
io volevo soltanto fare livelli natalizi
però allora mi sono due le cose io sono
lo annuncia che tu sei una cazzo di
coppia davvero sono vivo dove è
possibile a sopravvivere no io stavo
scherzando prima non pensava bene è che
l'altro c'è la bottiglia nel pene a me
sei un rush di testa roba che bello è
una roba welcome to make mi piace ma
cos'è sta roba sinceramente eccolo
eccolo preso così come ho fatto a
prendergli un ciao ho fatto una prezzo
incredibile una di roba l'ho preso vabbè
continuerà lui da solo ma il look byoc
vincitutto vinci qualsiasi cosa
prendimi orgoglioso perfetto ragazzi ha
preso solo liberi natalizi kris kris ma
spendiamo così kris kris man l'uomo
cristo ho sbagliato a scrivere noi ok
christmas special ragazzi chris marcoule
per questo da come primo era un natale
bello e tutti quanti lo stavano
festeggiando
ma il padre uk ero annoiato e decise di
andare a fare parkour
cosa backflip cosa ma dove è morto aiuto
una cosa che se per caso vostro padre si
rigira che questo natale e noioso non
ascoltate o se vuole andare in bici per
cortesia cos'è cos'è sta roba bellissima
ho vinto ho perso una gamba abbiamo
detto intanto babbo natale serve a
questo ma voglio una gamba per natale
perfetto
siamo partiti da dio complimenti
response rock swing c'è anche l'ok swing
natalizio mi carica bellissima no babbo
ma babbo natale su sui rock swing serio
com'è possibile sta cosa
proviamoci devo capire perfetto come
madonna se babbo e così ho preso da non
raggiungere gli obiettivi perché li
mettete ti serve aiuto zio
no perché io sono messo benissimo giuro
pensasse babbo natale deve fare stoccato
in ogni volta per portare qui cazzo di
regali dai vai dirla su quel tacchino
che è mangiato ieri per madonna che
schifo ceb affanculo ragazzi fa fare un
rock swing con babbo natale un po come
fare
non lo so una gara di corsa con i sacchi
impossibile se ci siamo che stavolta ci
siamo è tolta ci siamo c'è grazie a dio
è stato 3 se non c'era il muro davanti
invisibile avrei potuto imprecare di
brutto sappiatelo crisi al suo volto è
la madonna che paghi anche con babbo
natale sto livello fantastico
vabbè quelle morto perché cin 1 cech che
capisce android a che livello è questo
piano piano no no babbo regalati un paio
d'occhiali per natale perché mica non
vedi una sicura che non sto a prendere
niente
ok ok era l'ultima invece un prezzo l'ho
preso era l'ultima spacca è culo
ho vinto crismas folla c'è anche la
caduta di natale ma posso prenderlo
babbo ti darò un regalo se vinci ma
allora vince lo sarò
ho vinto ho vinto tutto ma si può
arrivare la finisco a livello no no
direi di no dai
si no sul cavallo vai vai giù ce l'ha
fatta
giovanna non ce l'ha fatta a cazzo vabbè
è finito momento c'è cos'è successo
ecco qua prendi un video un bidone ok io
sono morto perché sono caduto sul bidone
di babbo natale non poter immettere
direttamente nel turismo
matri search mancava proprio qualcosa
che sa di natale sto livello me lo
dovete far capire ragazzi perché non c'è
un altro allora ok allora va bene un po
più di natale perfetto che i suoi
adventure you see your presence dott
non prendere questo è un ascia grazie a
tutti vogliono lascia per natale e
tirarsela sul naso è proprio quello che
speravo complimenti bravo bel regalo
comunque devi saperlo potrei spaccare il
monitor quella moderna
ma perché non sei lanciare un cazzo dai
zio ma poi fa bravo bravo perché ha
ordinato a chiedere perché hai chiesto
un ascia natale se non sai usarla non è
così che si guida io sono convinto
proprio ogni giorno che passa mi
stupisci sempre di più ed i complimenti
per la guida ce l'ho fatta amen
stavolta ci sono riuscito ok cosa no non
ottieni te lo regala peso minacciato una
bolla perfetto bello lo voglio vicino
quell'altro sono morto basta mi sono
scansata ma è la ventesima volta che lo
rifaccio non salirò più su quel motorino
di merda crismas run cos'è è cascato un
cubo non era un regalo quello un cubo
abello voi sperate che babbo natale non
faccia alla fine quest'anno e che è mite
tragico dovevo saltare per ci ha scritto
fai santa fly effettivamente mai mai mai
mai mai mai mai mai mai mai
il cazzo di livello ma no ma come noi
sono riuscite a cadere uguale ma com'è
possibile fermi un attimo che devo
provarci mai maledizione mai mai mai mai
mai mai mai saluta sì stavolta sì c'è
perfetto è stato difficile ma perfetto
the fake santa il falso babbo natale e
quello io sono il vero babbo e porti
regali perfetta ucciso un bambino ma son
dettagli quelli succede a natale
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye no cosa che
sta succedendo in un suo caffè bello
complimenti parking lot a parcheggio
se avete capito anche solo una minima
cosa di sto livello fatelo sapere chi lo
fa in perfetto questo bello e molto più
bello di quanto pensassi soffrire le
pene della morte dell'inferno anche
uguale non è abbastanza però non c'ho
voglia di tartassati le balle quindi
vada sono i personaggi più belli che
abbia mai visto q pazzo di neve fanta
complimenti devo farlo pupazzo di neve
quest'anno ci provo poi mimando la foto
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye sea perfetto
ce la posso fare
sono ancora vivo è il natale di merda
fate vedere se c'è qualcosa di mio come
al solito fa vincendo una virgola e per
cento cioè favi sei un mito vi poi
salutare nel tuo video di harris
xd ma c'è ma è ovvio ma è ovvio xd che
ti saluto ciao xd come stai ci provo lo
stesso ragazzi anche se madonna vivo
perfetto sono esposte 700 bones niente
figli di pitti madonna mia mano anche i
miei sono imposti borse cose fantastico
sì sì no non ci credo ho vinto lo stesso
ho vinto uguale frega un cazzo fatto
talmente una cosa epica tanto quanto
questa posizione bella che non posso non
vince da una figata
e incredibile oggi non suscita fini e
mezzo di bello sarà presa già un proprio
che a natale riceverò legali brutti
invece sì no no no mi incazzo ho vinto
basta convinto
adesso ho vinto non l'ho messa io questa
cosa ho vinto e vasto che ai licei
proviamoci 60 per cento passivo è
bellissima la scritta qua come se non si
capisce dove devo andare non c'è scritto
proprio qua da farmi anche la freccetta
che indicava la scritta qua cosi capito
che devo buttarmi grazie comunque cazzo
no non sono entrato ma veramente in
città per noi si gioca
ho vinto ho vinto vinto vinto cos'è cosa
da fare è maledizione nonno che stai
facendo ascoltami già una giornata di
merda non tisci metri bruxelles
potevi e mangiare la pasta è stato
istruttivo ma non lo continuo grazie
luca ragazzi è stato un bellissimo
auguro buon natale a tutti non va beh
non importa perché questo un video non
era proprio prova al natale vede vabbè
ci prova con due episodi o perché no
avuto abbastanza di paura che arrivi
natale perché ho la fobia alle sole nato
non lo so è successo di tutto quindi non
ho idea però va bene così se nei video è
piaciuto la solita lasciato momento mi
piace anche a portieri facebook e come
non i video trovate la descrizione sull
sicuri si dice che riuscì vediamo al
prossimo vive ricordatevi che i folletti
sono cattive ma cattive persone
giuro beh ragazzi